vraiment que la mère du minotaure j'ai
plus son nom c'est une meuf qui
voulaient voir ce que ça faisait de se
faire prendre par un taureau ah ouais
ouais
alors on peut vérifier wang hao wang
girl bull il faut combler film heat
l'âge et je me rappelle plus trop mais
je crois qu'elle dépensera un costume de
vache assez mis dedans
ah ouais je crois à la vérité elle vient
après one girl touboul
voilà comment rendre un truc du coup
c'est au début tu t'es même pas
présenter quoi seraient pas présentés
non plus le genre on a fait comme si
c'était évident antennes selon lequel du
coup c'est le ban a dit non je vais vous
inquiéter maintenant je suis pas sûr que
tous ceux qui me suivent te connaissent
est ce que tu te présenter oui je me
présentais basique rivera vous que je
m'appelle madrid sergi de mostar je
bossais cergy le nombril nombril otepää
voilà je me pourrit pour facebook
la baisse des montants mais moi je
dirais je propose parce que c'est
nombriliste facebook bref et du coup
jean chain l'histoire de cherchell
toujours qui s'appelle c'est une autre
histoire
ok donc on y parle histoire autrement
ouais de manière moins je trouve de
manière fun punchy boy miles hockey et
je trouve qu'il ya ce côté un peu que
j'élève que j'aime beaucoup d'un coup de
fil mais c'est normal vous savez c'est
un peu ce que de dire ça mais ce côté un
peu
chill et et hip hop oui grave tu à
l'écart fond à la culture urbaine un peu
dans la rue et tout et oui d'ailleurs je
t'avais et crise début de la chaîne
parce que j'ai je trouvais que nothomb
se ressembler ouais tout à fait gérable
du coup ça fait vachement qu'ils
absorbent un appareil j'étais très
content de cas aujourd'hui on va se
poser une question
on va se demander si la limite avait été
de l'histoire ouais après plémy de la
mythologie grecque et romaine parce que
effectivement sinon si on part sont
toutes les mythologies ça va être le
bordel ça va vite est pas possible
ouais cissé
vraiment arriver tout cas le principe
c'est le générique la voix la cgt fait
en générique je peux tu imagines si ya
pas encore les génériques mais
aujourd'hui c'est ma mourir ben ali
t'imagines si ya pas encore de
génériques mais ça arrive eh ben je vais
commencer ma vie ok alors attends je me
fais bien
ben ali serait prendre notre temps
tranquille un type un peu chaud un peu
chaud trop chaud c'est peut-être aussi
que la couverture le thé tout c'est vrai
il a fait de la chaire bas soit en elle
un truc ou si la mythologie grecque
avait existé
la consanguinité seraient monnaie
courante inceste oblige alors c'est vrai
que oui non parce que effectivement
gérer avec mon gars d'aller oui non un
effet vinci pas forcément ce que l'on
sait que la race et on peut imaginer que
c'est une fille après oui j'ai proposé
magie oui et non dans le sens où
effectivement les dieux entre eux ils
baissent beaucoup entre eux et beaucoup
de consanguinité en mettant un petit peu
obligé les mecs parce que au début et
cesser les seuls êtres sur terre toi
donc c'est vrai et c'est mérité
donc il faut si tu veux peuple est un
peu le truc qui sont un peu obligé ni
qu'entre eux mêmes après quand il ya
plus de monde il continue quand même à
entre eux mais ça c'est pas un
problème chez dieu mes parents chez les
mortels c'est seynod et c'est interdit
et les dieux l'acceptent pas s'il va ou
non fait non non mais le grand l'exempt
super connu c'est oedipe oui le dip
il a tué son papa est là tuez samarie là
qui a tué son papa et a couché avec sa
mère elle me vient de spoil et sophocle
super est allé alors il n'a pas fait
exprès d'ailleurs il savait pas mais
bref il l'a fait et il a été plus parler
de l'offre
il s'adapte c'est vrai c'était pas moins
sévère qu'ailleurs il a même essayé
d'éviter que ça arrive tous et cela rend
ma chance en bref
du coup voilà
la peste qui s'abat sur thèbes et c'est
donc les dieux je me dis dieu punit
s'élancer chez les mortels rojo même si
même si ça avait vraiment existé ouais
bah pour nous l'art c'est ça serait un
terreau pour les humains ouais non non
c'est interdit s'ils évitent au logis
existait réellement ça remettrait tout
les fondements des religions actuelles
orientale qu en péril des religions
actuelles auront d'ailleurs pays de par
l'existence de dieu présent de plus déjà
ça effectivement les monothéismes par
exemple n'aurait pas pu arriver que si
les dieux il existait vraiment si
c'était l'histoire que c'est dieu là
existaient en bas de fait il n'aurait
pas laissé par exemple vous aurez pas
les cg du ballet limite jésus sur les
terrains clampins qui y willis excité
puis l'aurait terrain voilà il n'y a pas
de croyance à avoir que le mec il est là
on est oui a vu de croyance les
religions orientales
c'est donc ses limites un bon il la
question à monsieur hockey avant paris
de plus les fils des dieux les
demi-dieux engendrerait un chamboulement
de la société avec de véritables
différences de force
enfin toujours dans le changement de la
société que serions nous avec à
disposition de la corne d'abondance
tonnerre de zeus en majuscules ça je
vais je l'exprimé comme j'ai lu tu va
sublimer
alors les fils des dieux et les
demi-dieux engendrerait un changement de
la steg de véritables différences de
force et ouais ça serait ses clacs ça
serait des surhommes moi ce serait
peut-être des genres de super héros
c'est sûr qu'ils ont trois tout ce qu'il
m'a dit alors dans les fils de dieu y en
a qui sont mortels y en a qui sont
immortels ça dépend meiway en général
ils sont gros singe aime quoi la
mortalité the jews chiappucci fs oui
c'est clair sur il ya pas trop
d'explications sarcelles mais certains
naissent bas dionysos il est alors us
est pleinement un dieu mais il est né
d'une mortelle et de deux et c'est un
dieu et jose ouais je pas t'expliquer
sont là dessus je crois pas qu'il en est
et héraclès il est né aussi de la
mortelle halonen et de zeus mais elle
est mortelle et après par contre les
moeurs et elle est divisée a accepté par
mail et dieu tu vois mes
c'est dans le film de disney ça ne va
pas du tout le film de disney s'est
sacrément différent de la caisse c'est
quand même un type qui a buté sa femme
et ses gosses tu donc exactement six et
ils ont ils ont pas lui ça peut
comprendre
donc il ya ça effectivement c'est vrai
qu'il y aurait peut-être des véritables
différentes de forge voir les mecs ibrir
être aux jeux olympiques et tous et et
enfin toujours dans le changement de la
société que seront noués avec la
disposition de la corne d'abondance
énorme empêche genre hey hey c'est ça
moi c'était dans la rue comme ça en fin
de marché je repousse avec qui ce prix
là encore un fils de dieu
enfin en 2010 jean ça ferait des castes
peut-être un peu oui oui des différences
sociales ouais bah ouais t'es ce serait
d'en laisser tomber ce serait dans les
bio facebook twitter des demi-dieux tous
les veufs et veuves ostap et demi dieu
avec bruxelles david et s est donc la
grande abondance et ben qu'est ce qu'on
ferait que la corne d'abondance vrai que
ça serait assez dense c'est dans un but
précis l'attendait à bandes la corne
d'abondance et une corde qui se vident
jamais bien à tout le temps que la voie
qu'ils n'ont c'est donc je trouve ça
parce que tu veux comme la chef qui a
allaité zeus du coup il est tout le
temps remplirait de trucs et se vit bien
mais c'est un symbole aussi tu mets ta
pour représenter à l'abondance et c'est
comme quand quoi ouais c'est un gros
truc oui ça c'est clairement taille trop
chargé parce que en même temps tu vois
ce genre si ça existait vraiment tunique
toute l'industrie agroalimentaire quoi
sauf que meredith plein jobs tunis - oui
et non parce que l'imagination
si le truc qui sort une pomme bon hockey
et ta pomme tu la sors ici à paris non
mais tu dis que tous les agriculteurs de
fond n'est pas pro bas du coin mais tu
peux pas les envoyer ou alors fouillé
allez quoi pour envoyer toutes les
pommes jusqu'à nourrir tout le monde
avant qu'elles soient périmées et tous
maintenant tous les coins dans tous les
cas il ya un coin que tu viens crois
qu'il sera un peu dit il faut que tu
défends semaine pour l envoyer un
endroit si on est intelligent on la
mettra un endroit où l'agriculteur est
très difficile quoi ouais mais peut-être
aimé ça peut produire d'autres trucs que
de la bouffe tu as ça peut produire de
l'argent par exemple avoir créé une plus
tard l'inflation et donc oui je pense qu
on la prendrait des risques ont saccagé
les mâles ont la cacherai j'aurais six
milieux souffert
faudrait détruire ans si la vitesse y
c'est l'histoire j'ai un peu mal pour le
mec se fait bouffer tous les jours ses
entrées elles allaient tous ces mets
c'est profiter des scènes pro métiers
bah ouais le pauvre parce que lui mais
ça ça doit pas trop me cogner pour
toujours il ya certaines personnes qui
disent qui raclent est ce le seul
d'ailleurs il est gentil sa part à tuer
ça paraît difficile à fait plein de
trucs que les bus passent et les gentils
méchants avait s'habitue pas et c'est
juste plus à un gros brin bellatrix
encore ce qui l'intéressé mechanical
systems et son symbole c'est une massue
oui non mais c'est pas la fine et c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment aimé que bourrin
quoi
mais après il aurait tué sa femme et ses
gosses parce que ra leur ai vendu faut
donc ses moyens sa faute mais s'est fait
la main en bois quand il était ado il a
débuté son prof de musique ou de super
peps à le soumettre à un peu concon à
hercules n'en disaient qu'est m
ouais mais à mon avis de ce que tu dis
là les grecs ils devaient vraiment
libéré genre genre odeurs quoi oui oui
et non enfin wade et après ses qualités
vénéré aussi tu vois c'est un ensemble
du peuple since assez rigolo parce que
c'est bas ça c'est les élites qui
construit ces images aussi mais ouais
héraclès donc gros besoin c'est un
symbole du peuple sur ce théâtre là bref
on aurait tous plus ou moins des
ascendants divin à l'heure actuelle de
ce ne serait plus le roi de la pop parce
que tout le monde le havrais
les hommes sont donc c'est lui qui a
envoyé la boîte de pandore avec la
maladie la guerre la compagnie ils sont
donc c'est une vraie enflure et que les
dieux sont pas forcément bon puisqu'il
viole menthe trompe et c'est peut-être
qu'un autre dieu prendra sa place
pourquoi pas essayer au wat et n'a en
tous cas l'élection du nouveau roi fera
naître des guerres entre les hommes qui
ont chacun leur camp et ça sera encore
un gros ce bug ou alors le fait que même
les dieux se met au viol à l'inceste au
meurtre et au mensonge extra ça va
conduire à un monde hyper chelou où tous
les concepts de morale seront différents
alors je pense pas enfin à l'envi je
reprends tranquillement les en fait
alors nous tous plus ou moins des
ascendants divin à l'heure actuelle
parce que ça je pense c'est parce que
2,6 ils s'aiment beaucoup et je pense
pas non plus pour sûr mais tout à fait à
semences voilà
ça et on le haïr et non ça je pense
vraiment pas parce que dans la grèce
antique cd mythe qu'on raconte
on lie pas pour ça c'est en fait il n'y
a pas de rapport y'a pas le rapport
affectif odieuse est beaucoup plus
utilitaire en fait tu leur donnes un
culte pour avoir des bonnes faveurs pour
pouvoir faire ceci ou cela mais y'a pas
dimension morale ou autre comme ça c'est
pas ce pas du tout même rapport que lui
la création de bornes monothéistes
vraiment on n'a pas ce côté paternaliste
il ya des garçons d'amour il ya une
dimension de morale effectivement et là
c'est vraiment pas ce genre de rapport
que les grecs anciens ils ont avec leur
dignité
pas du tout donc on saurait ce qu'il en
soit on sentait qu'ils font ça et on
serait obligé de l'événement parce que
si on veut par exemple lancer une guerre
et tout autre objet de deux j'espère
qu'on sacrifie une vache at-elle
divinité pour pour pouvoir réussir nos
batailles tout en sachant qu'on ferait
tout ça et que du coup ça ça n'est vrai
enfin bref on ira chercher plein de rage
de gros carrés on éponge et sacrifier
des amis pour les dunes qui tu peux
faire des libations de vin ou des choses
comme ça ou des céréales
bref qu'on peut faire vivre joxe on peut
faire des sacrifices des gaines et donc
c'est une religion très pratique en fait
c'est vraiment je dois bien faire le
rite je dois bien effectuer le culte
pour pouvoir mener à bien mon action et
ma vie mais il n'y a pas de jeu j'ai
envie que
j'aime dessous d'eux mêmes ou juste à
quoi tu t'imagines ces genres tintin
dieu qui est contre des genres qui est
et qui les commandent hyper
conservateurs et qu elle pas que les
réfugiés viennent en france et ou sur la
mer médard des élans saison à dents et
oui mais exactement que me poséidon qui
nuit à ulysse quand il veut rentrer chez
lui par exemple il lui faut des tempêtes
marchand il fait ses choux et ailleurs
carrière - se mêlerait de sa part contre
les dieux existera encore oui puisqu'ils
sont immortels bien qu'on ait cessé de
prier pour eux non il faut qu on serait
obligé de les vénère et parce que sinon
on pourrait pas à réussir dans la vie
dans nos vignes il nous entraverait tout
le temps quoi il faut il faut appliquer
les rituels et les codes comme il faut
s'il existe on serait obligé de leur
rendre leurs sacrifices leur machin et
tout quoi la sélection de réussite dans
sa vie genre qui aujourd'hui c'est en
fonction en moi ça peut être attaqué sur
professionnelle mais ça peut être aussi
genre ton mérite gens le travail que tu
fais et c'est un machin ton implication
là il y aurait en plus toute une
dimension genre à quel point tu vénères
il est dur et oui est ce qu'était jean
il a réussi son concours mais parce
qu'en même temps ils loïc il a fait un
machin mais du coup tu aurais peut-être
des aides sociales de l'état qui se
mettra en place pour aider les gens qui
peuvent pas qu'ils ont pas les moyens
d'enquêté comprend des toutefois
peut-être vraiment une religion
institutionnalisée code barre des gens
seraient dans une religion d'état quoi
c'est clair ça existe vraiment très
envie de faire avec
ouais donc l'état peut-être aiderez les
gens à sacrifier au nom jean jacques
durand et enfin il y aura un ministère
pour chaque dieu qui le représente par
exemple ça il aurait des institutions
sans doute tu vois et après des fois
c'est pas parce que tu sacrifies odieux
que ta demande et honorer un forcément
toujours efficaces soient pas ce qu'est
ce que tu as passé un bon voix je me
suis un peu fait chier mais je trouve
dans la bas j'espère réseau après un
moment parce que c'est surtout moqué par
les quoi mais ça dépend des images iliad
et imagine ce que j'apprends beaucoup
ouais ça va être à côté de là j'ai
beaucoup appris voit ses coûts et djibel
j'ai pas dit trop de conneries des fois
faut veille qui est peut-être un peu je
ne mélange pas trop aux limites ou quoi
donc faut bien au pire tu es
c'est une chaîne il ya beaucoup de
comoriens de façon un peu un peu moins
voilà mais parfois il ya des gens qui
font directive dans les commentaires et
pas très bien mais moi je les épingler
ce seraient les bienvenus il ya des
rectifications ça
mais non j'ai beaucoup appris et c'est
pour ça que j'ai moins j'aimerais en
parler que sur deux épisodes ou sait
plus où vous faites un exercice de
pensée entre way à temps mais là j'ai un
certain sens j'espère que les gens ont
appris des trucs aussi et pas à venir en
apprend plus ouais j'ai exactement
si vous qui fait la mythologie voilà ce
que j'ai à dire parfois quand je fais
des vidéos de mise auditoire trop cool
on aime bien conseillé de limiter tout
maintenant est que ça à gogo bref je
mets le lien de ma mémoire des émissions
et sa chaîne dans la vidéo call yes en
tout cas merci merci merci les nuls
c'est un sujet hyper hyper intéressant
pour prochain t'imagines si la question
là voilà tu imagines si les élections
présidentielles avait lieu sur youtube
avec hugo traverse de la chaîne hugo
décrypte je vous donne quelques
précisions supplémentaires parce que la
question est assez synthétique ça ne
change rien jusqu'au moment où on est
candidate elle qu'il faut 500 signatures
ce que ça change c'est qu'en fait c'est
pas le candidat avec le plus de votes
qui gagne mais celui avec le plus
d'abonnements sur youtube et donc
pouvait répondre oui ça c'est une arme
alain j'ai toujours voulu savoir quoi
j'ai trop hâte trop c'est trop il faut
la même blague à chaque fois ils
connaissent pas la question encore en
tout cas
vous pouvez y répondre d'ores et déjà
dans les commentaires de la vidéo et
merci merci de la remercie pour vos
questions à chaque fois enfin vos
réponses plutôt je pense et pertinents
moi c'est drôle
certes elle a rigolé en lisant vos trucs
et bon courage pour cette année 1017
réussi dans tous vos projets assiette
l'année de la fête
amour santé réussite bonheur tout ça
ouais ciao salut by a plus à la bdl chez
à la prochaine je sais pas quoi dire
ciao à bientôt à tout à l'heure sur ma
chaîne basque damien
ah oui mais toi tu récites toutes les
ondes en plus ok moi je peux dire good
bye
voilà tu vois avant un bon épisode puis
tu es tu sois goodbye à la fin quand je
te baiser port de cassis et non mais
voilà jean tremblay président tous les
gens qui parlent anglais c'est ça non si
c'est ce que tu viens de faire alors